con pancartas que le da la bienvenida al
autodenominado nuevo gobierno y diciendo
que esto marca la nueva era de la
revolución de la primavera así es como
decenas de manifestantes salieron a las
calles una vez más en mi andar para
protestar en contra de la junta militar
y también para respaldar al llamado
gobierno de unidad nacional una idea que
crearon el pasado viernes políticos pro
democracia y parte de los parlamentarios
derrocados
no le va a decir a la democracia federal
puede mejorar el sistema educativo los
problemas sociales las relaciones
internacionales las empresas como
estudiantes estamos muy contentos de ver
la formación del gobierno de unidad
nacional
pero los líderes militares siguen firmes
de hecho el jefe de la junta birmana
ming online asistirá a la cumbre que
celebrará la asean que es la asociación
de las 10 naciones del sudeste asiático
la cita será en indonesia el próximo 24
de abril esta será la primera vez que
los militares que asumieron el poder por
la fuerza participarán en una reunión
internacional mientras el autodenominado
gobierno de unidad le pide a la asean
que rechace a la junta y que reconozca
al gobierno paralelo como el legítimo
otra de las noticias en mianmar es la
liberación de presos un portavoz del
departamento de prisiones confirmó que
indultaron a más de 23.000 reos como
parte de un perdón judicial por el año
nuevo budista que se celebra en el país
este sábado sin embargo se desconoce si
los insultados incluyen a algunos de los
más de 3.100 manifestantes prodemocracia
que han sido detenidos desde el golpe de
estado